>> Greg: DURING A COMMENCEMENT
SPEECH IN TEXAS SATURDAY, FORMER
NEW YORK CITY MAYOR MICHAEL
BLOOMBERG SAID AMERICA IS FACING
AN EPIDEMIC OF DISHONESTY THAT
IS WORSE THAN TERROR.
>> THE GREATEST THAT TO AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY ISN'T COMMUNISM OR
JIHAD IS HIM OR ANY OTHER
POWER.
IT'S OUR OWN WILLINGNESS TO
TOLERATE DISHONESTY IN SERVICE
OF PARTY AND IN PURSUIT OF POWER
OF PARTY AND IN PURSUIT OF POWE
POWER.
>> Greg: MY MIC FELL OFF.
BLOOMBERG THINKS WORDS FROM
TRUMP ARE DEADLIER THAN DEEDS
FROM A TERRORIST WHICH LEADS ONE
TO ASK WHEN BLOOMBERG WAS MAYOR
OF NEW YORK CITY, WHAT DO YOU
THINK IS NUMBER ONE CONCERN WAS?
DO YOU THINK HE WOKE UP EVERY
MORNING AND THOUGHT I HOPE
SOMEONE IS NOT LYING ON THEIR
TAX RETURNS?
INSTEAD HE WAS FOCUSED ON
TERRORISM.
NUMBER ONE THREAT TO
NEW YORK CITY AND AMERICA WAS
AND STILL IS TERRORISM.
NOT WHETHER TRUMP EXAGGERATES
ABOUT MEXICO PAYING FOR THE
WALL.
FOR BLOOMBERG TO EXPRESS HIS OWN
GRAPES LIKE CLIMATE CHANGE OR
SMOKING OR GUN CONTROL, FIRST HE
HAD TO KEEP THE CITY SAFE SO HE
COULD HAVE THE LUXURY OF GRIPING
COULD HAVE THE LUXURY OF GRIPIN
GRIPING.
NOW IN A SPEECH WHEN HE REORDERS
OUR CONCERNS JUST TO JAB
DONALD TRUMP COME HE IS
COMMITTING THE VERY SIN.
HE IS FALSIFYING FACTS.
THE ONLY 11 CAN COMPLAIN ABOUT
PARTISANSHIP BEING WORSE THAN
COMMUNISM IS TO DIMINISH THE
PILES OF BODIES CAUSED BY BOTH.
ALL OF THIS COULD BE DUE TO ONE
TRUTH.
RIGHT NOW TRUMP MAY MAKE HISTORY
WITH THE KOREAS AND BLOOMIE IS
WHINING ABOUT FAKE NEWS AT A
COLLEGE.
THAT'S GOT TO HURT.
JESSE, DO YOU THINK THIS WAS
SOME KIND OF HYPERBOLE YOU DO IN
A SPEECH?
HE CAN'T REALLY MEAN THAT THIS
IS WORSE THAN TERROR OR
COMMUNISM.
>> Jesse: NOW, A LIE DIDN'T
FLY INTO A BUILDING AND KILLED
3,000 PEOPLE.
I AM AVAILABLE TO DO
COMMENCEMENT IF ANYONE IS
INTERESTED.
I WOULD LOOK GOOD IN THE CASTLE.
>> Greg: IT WAS A NICE OUTFIT.
THEY LOOK AT WAITERS IN MEDIEVAL
RESTAURANTS.
>> Jesse: MEDIEVAL TIMES.
HAVE YOU BEEN THERE RECENTLY?
>> Greg: I.E. THERE EVERY
NIGHT.
>> Jesse: HOW DO YOU KNOW WHEN
A POLITICIAN IS LYING?
HIS LIPS ARE MOVING.
EVERY POLITICIAN LIES.
I WOULD RATHER HAVE A POLITICIAN
LIE ABOUT SEX OR CROWD SIZE AND
ABOUT NOT BEING ABLE TO KEEP
YOUR HEALTH CARE OR TERRORISM
FACTS.
THERE IS WHITE LIES AND THEN
THERE'S WHOPPERS.
THIS WAS CLEARLY A SHOT AT TRUMP
THIS WAS CLEARLY A SHOT AT TRUM
TRUMP.
I THINK THE FAKE NEWS PUTS OUT
MAY BE THE SAME AMOUNT OF JOKES
AS PRESIDENT TRUMP DOES, IF NOT
MORE.
I HAVE THE FAKE NEWS MEDIA WORDS
HERE AND I'M HAPPY TO RECITE
THEM.
THAT'S FINE.
AT THE SAME TIME, I DON'T THINK
TRUMP IS A LIAR.
I THINK HE HAS A POSTER.
CLEANS REAL ESTATE TYCOON.
BIGGEST, BEST, MOST EXPENSIVE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE CONSIDER THOSE
OPINIONS LIES.
THEY WILL FACT-CHECK HIS
OPINIONS.
HE WILL SAY I'M THE BEST LOOKING
PRESIDENT THERE EVER IS AND THEN
THE PINOCCHIO PEOPLE
FACT-CHECKING.
>> Greg: IT'S LIKE A CAR
SALESMAN SANG A LITTLE OLD LADY
JUST DROVE THIS CAR TO CHURCH ON
SUNDAYS AND EVERYONE IS WINKING.
SHOULD BLOOMBERG APOLOGIZED TO
AMERICA FOR WHAT HE JUST DID?
>> Juan: I DON'T KNOW WHERE
YOU HAVE TO START WITH THE
APOLOGIES.
I >> Greg: EVERY SINGLE
AMERICAN.
>> Juan: TRUMP.
TRUMP SHOULD APOLOGIZE.
YOU SAID THIS IS SHOCKING.
YOU WOULD BE SURPRISED HOW MANY
PEOPLE IN THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY.
I THINK BACK TO LEON PANETTA AND
JOHN BRENNAN.
PEOPLE WHO SAY IT IS THE BIGGEST
THREAT TO US AS A NATION, THIS
KIND OF DIVIDE BECAUSE IT'S JUST
WHAT THE RUSSIANS WANT.
WE CAN'T DECIDE ANYTHING.
EVERYTHING IS A HUGE ARGUMENT.
LAST WEEK I WROTE A COLUMN AND
SAID WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT WENT
ON IN TERMS OF THE DECISION TO
PULL THE UNITED STATES AWAY FROM
THE IRAN DEAL, THE PRESIDENT
WITH HIS BOASTFULNESS, I THINK
IT'S PERSUASIVE TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
THE IRAN DEAL HAS BEEN VIOLATED.
IT WAS A WEAK, TERRIBLE DEAL.
YET THE FACT IS THE DEAL WAS
NEVER VIOLATED BUT THE FACT IS
PEOPLE SAY THIS WAS KEEPING IRAN
FROM HAVING NUKES.
NOW SUDDENLY THEY SAY WELL MAYBE
IT WAS A BAD DEAL.
MAYBE IT'S A PARTISAN FIGHT.
MAYBE HE DOESN'T LIKE
JOHN KERRY.
WE LOSE SIGHT OF THE TRUTH.
WE CAN'T EVEN GET ANYTHING DONE.
>> Greg: NOW THAT JUAN HAS
DEFLECTED, KIMBERLY HOW ABOUT A
TOTALLY DIFFERENT TOPIC?
BLOOMBERG IS MAD HE DIDN'T RUN
FOR PRESIDENT.
>> Kimberly: HE IS MAD THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS HONORED HIS
CAMPAIGN PROMISES AND CHECKING
OFF WINDS.
ANYONE WHO LOVES THIS COUNTRY
SHOULD BE HAPPY WE ARE MOVING
TOWARDS THESE.
THAT THE ECONOMY IS DOING
BETTER.
EVERYONE SHOULD BE HAPPY THERE'S
MORE JOBS IN AMERICA AND THAT
MINORITIES ARE FEELING BETTER
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THIS
COUNTRY.
SO MANY ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND AS
IT RELATES TO NATIONAL SECURITY
AND FOREIGN POLICY, HE HAS
COMPLETELY, COMPLETELY CHANGE
THE DYNAMIC.
THIS IS A NEW STYLE OF POLITICS
AND ENGAGING TO CREATE EFFECTIVE
RESULTS.
WHY NOT?
IF YOU KEEP DOING THE SAME THING
AND YOU END UP WITH THE END
RESULT, WHY NOT TRY A DIFFERENT
WAY OR A DIFFERENT PATH?
ALSO PRESIDENT TRUMP IS USING
SOCIAL MEDIA AND TWITTER TO BE
ABLE TO COMMUNICATE SO THERE IS
TRANSPARENCY THERE VERSUS
SOMEONE REGURGITATING, GOING
THROUGH IT AND PUTTING SOMETHING
OUT.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S A DOWNSIDE
TO THAT BECAUSE EVERY PERSON CAN
DETERMINE WHAT YOU THINK OF IT
VERSUS SOMEONE TELLING YOU WHAT
TO THINK.
>> Juan: THERE'S A TREMENDOUS
DOWNSIDE TO CONSTANT LYING FROM
THE MAN WHO WAS THE PRESIDENT,
THE LEADER OF THE COUNTRY.
PEOPLE CAN'T TRUST HIM.
>> Greg: WE ARE NEVER GOING TO
SOLVE THIS.
>> Dana: I THINK EVERY
COMMENCEMENT SPEECH WOULD BE
MORE SUCCESSFUL IF IT MADE NO
NEWS.
IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT THE
STUDENTS COME UP FOR THEM TO GO
OUT INTO THE WORLD, TO CELEBRATE
THE FACT THAT THEY ARE GETTING
THROUGH COLLEGE.
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE A CHANCE
TO GO MAKE THEIR MARK ON THE
WORLD, AND WORRYING ABOUT FAKE
NEWS IS NOT THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY.
>> Greg: I WANT TO DO A
COMMENCEMENT ADDRESS FOR AN